Hello everyone, I
'm the sister of r, the legendary producer of Zelda,
but with other wires and the Breath of the World, I created a really vast post-content
world.
That
's why we decided to develop the first additional content for the Zero Legend series.
This additional content is
scheduled to be distributed in two parts, the summer of 2017 and the end of the year, and will be released in 2017.
Scheduled for March 3 Click
here for an overview of the additional content
[Music]
We would like to provide zero new fun with these two
additional contents.
I want you to play for a long time, explore for a long time, and burn for a long time. Thank you.